The Floyd-Warshall Algorithm has neat
connection to finding the transitive
closure of mathematical relations
that I want to cover briefly.
Consider a relation R over set A.
That is to say,
R is a subset of A cross A.
For example, A might represent sports
that one can watch on television and
the relation might be
someone's viewing preferences.
Maybe this individual prefers
NBA to college basketball and
NBA to college football,
and we also know that he prefers
college football to pro football.
Since a relation is just
a collection of ordered pairs,
it makes sense to represent
them as a directive graph.
And given these preferences, we would
like to be able to infer that this
individual prefers the NBA
over the NFL as well.
In effect, if there's a path
from one vertex into another,
we'd like to add a direct
edge between them.
In set theory, this is called
the transitive closure of a relation.
Given what we know already,
there's a fairly simple solution.
Just give each edge weight 1,
and then run Floyd-Warshall.
The distance will be infinity
if there's not a path,
and it will be the minimum number
of edges traversed otherwise.
This is more information
than we really need however.
We really just want to know whether
there is a path, not how long it is.
Hence, in this context, we use
a slight variant where the entries in
the table are all booleans,
either 0 or 1, instead of integers.
But otherwise, the algorithm is
going to be essentially the same.
We initialize the table so
that the entry [i][j] is 1,
if (ai, aj) is in the relation,
and 0 otherwise.
Note that I'm letting a1
through an be the set A here.
Then we keep on adding potential
intermediate elements, and
updating the table accordingly.
Here [i][j], are in the relation, if
they're either in the relation already
or if k acts as a link between them.
Often, we're interested not in
the transitive closure of relation, but
in the reflexive transitive closure.
In this case,
we just set the diagonal elements
to be 1 from the beginning here.